I'm really emotional because my mother
my grandma my mom is saying my son is
here my grandmother is here and they are
why I do everything I do I work so hard
to make them proud because my
grandmother is 94 years old and she been
riding with me y'all she been to the
Oscars with me she's been to both Emmys
two Emmy
ceremonies with me and I know she's
praying for me cuz I know God is
listening and I know her prayers brought
me here I know she never thought she was
made to see this and grandma I hope you
are so proud because this is your legacy
congratulations on everything I mean you
literally had everyone in tears and
you're an example of the product of your
grandmother's prayers can you just talk
about how special it is to have her here
and any advice that she's given you that
you carry in your career today
I mean she just said she says she has so
many gems you put me on a spot I can't
think of them but what I love about my
grandmother is her unconditional love
she taught the family how to love and
she keeps us very close all my cousins
and I are really really close but of
course she prayed she did a lot of
praying and she continues to pray for me
and like I said in my speech her prayers
definitely brought me here so my
grandmother's my everything and then you
definitely had a baby boy moment with
John Singleton that we all loved and you
guys are teaming up for Emmett Till can
you talk about how hard that role is
retelling that and being a real-life
mother it's a it's a we haven't started
yet but
you know I'm it's gonna be bittersweet
because yes it's a story that absolutely
needs to be told but you know when I
played those dark I'm such a bright
person you know I'm like I'm dreading a
little bit having to stay in those
places for you know however long it
takes a fulfillment but I'm ready for it
I'm ready for the challenge because
again I do work that hopefully affects
and move humanity forward in a positive
way
[Music]